Everything has a
location, whether it
be the photos you
took, where you
are, the places you
like to hang out,
where you bought
that special gift,
or even the last place
you met your date.
I'm Megan Boundey
Product Manager
for the Google Maps Mobile SDKs.
Today I'm going to
show you some cool ways
to use Google Maps Mobile
SDKs, to help you both bring
these experiences alive, and
delight and engage your users.
In this session, I'm focusing on
the Google Maps Android API v2.
But all of this functionality
is available in the Google Maps
SDK for iOS as well.
This is great if you're looking
for cross-platform consistency
for your apps.
When developers think of
having a map in their app,
they often think of something
like this, a marker on a map.
This is great for
showing you a location
or marking out where you
might want to meet someone.
But did you know that you could
add Street View to your app
like this?
Or make cool apps,
like Santa Tracker,
that follow Santa around the
world as he delivers presents?
Let's take a look.
Our docs show you how to embed
a Google Map in an Android
activity.
Then it's easy to add
markers to your map.
You just use the
addMarker method
and specify a few options
to customize the Marker.
For example, you can set
latitude and longitude,
change the color of the Marker.
You can also set what
shows up in the Info Window
when the user taps the Marker
and the Info Window pops up.
You may even want to use
photos as your Marker.
Maybe you want to show where
the photo was taken on a map
and associate it with an
event, rather than just
showing a strip of
photos in your app.
Now that you've
seen Markers, let's
take a look at Street View.
Most excitingly, you can
add Street View imagery
to your apps.
In this demo, you can
see the split screen
with the Street View
imagery in the top half,
and the Google Map
in the bottom half.
By long pressing the
Marker and dragging,
Street View imagery
updates, and shows
you the location where
you dragged the Marker to.
So how do you do this?
A very similar demo is
available in the demo examples
in the Google Maps for
Android API v2 itself.
So the code is all there.
Here we've split the
layout into two parts.
There's one fragment for
the Street View panorama,
and one fragment
for the Google Map.
You then set the
same initial location
for the map, the Marker,
and the panorama.
And we've given our Marker a
custom icon, which is Pegman.
When you drag the Marker,
you listen to a drag event
from the Marker and
use the callback
to position the location
of the panorama.
When the panorama
change event occurs,
the listener will give
you the precise location
of the panorama, and you can
feed this back to the Marker
to update its position
completely accurately.
So what else can you
do with Street View?
You may want to add Street
View to your Store Locator,
see an area around a hotel, or
view a museum or an aquarium.
Street View also provides
you with seamless access
to Google's Indoor
Street View imagery.
You can set the
Street View panorama
to be of imagery
within the aquarium,
or set it outside the aquarium,
and have your users navigate
inside if they wish.
Of course, you can
do this for stores
as well, if the store has
indoor business view imagery.
This would be awesome
if you're a store owner
and you want your customers
to see what's available
inside to entice them
to come and visit you.
Moving on.
How can you make
your users feel more
immersed in their
Maps experience?
Have you tried out
the Santa Tracker app
and wondered why it felt so
movie-like to follow Santa
as he flies around the world?
This is because we made the
camera track Santa's location.
Both the Google Maps
Mobile SDKs use a camera
that lets you set the location
of what you want to look at.
You can animate the camera
by using a camera update
and calling the
animateCamera method.
This is where you can also set
the zoom level, the bearing,
the tilt, and the
duration of the animation.
It's so effective.
If you don't want to
see any animation,
you just call the
moveCamera method instead,
and it will move the map
directly to that new location.
We have a whole session
dedicated to the Santa Tracker
app at Google I/O 2014.
So make sure to take a look.
Now you know how
to make your users
feel more immersed in
their Maps experience,
how do you add things to
the map and animate them?
For example, how do
those weather apps
get their clouds coming
in over the terrain map?
Google Maps has several
map types available,
such as satellite,
hybrid, or terrain.
It's really easy to
switch between map types.
You just use the setMapType
method on the map
and specify the map
type that you want.
These apps are also using
mostly transparent tile overlays
with the clouds as
the opaque features.
Tile overlays allow you to
specify particular tiles
to be shown at a given
set of coordinates.
You should also
specify which tiles
can be shown at each zoom level.
All you need to do is to
find a urlTileProvider
and supply that to the
TileOverlay options.
Then add it to the map.
To make their clouds
appear to be moving,
the weather apps
are swapping out
multiple tile
overlays periodically
to make it appear animated.
Talking about the weather,
it may be time to go inside.
There's also the ability
to see indoor maps along
with with [? perkomatic ?]
control of the indoor level
of a building and
the floor picker.
You can find out
which building is
active by calling
getFocusedBuilding,
and then find out the active
level of that building
by calling getActiveLevelIndex.
This is great if
you want to show
Custom Markup for
the Active Level,
such as markers,
poly lines, tile
overlays, and other shapes.
You can also turn off
our default Level Picker
and implement your own by
passing false to the method
setIndoorLevelPickerEnabled
and then adding your own.
Now we've seen all parts of
the world via our map-- indoor,
outdoor, Street View, a
normal [INAUDIBLE] map,
and weather overlays.
Who knew you could so much
with Maps in your apps?
To get started mapping up your
own apps, go here for Android
and here for iOS.
And if you need any
help, our Support Page
lists the stackover
Play tags that you need.
So what are you waiting for?
It's time to get out there and
start mapping up your apps.